on ne sait plus quoi faire comme intro
aujourd'hui je voulais vous parler d'un
sujet ou d'un autre sujet j'ai eu du mal
à faire un choix soit les addictions
comment on et accroît quelque chose
comment ça se passe dans le cerveau y
tout soit les jeux vidéo parce que
j'aime bien les jeux vidéo et puis le
fait qu'il m'a dit m'a fait les deux pas
bête loïc
avec un petit peu oui oui tu parles très
très fort le matin est très fort je me
suis dit en vrai on peut faire une vidéo
où je vous parle du procédé d'addiction
à des jeux comme le jeu fortnight par
exemple il ya des gens qui sont allés à
l'hôpital à cause de leur addiction à
force nike il ya des médecins qui
soignent les addicts de fortnight à
l'aide d'un autre jeu vidéo etc c'est
assez passionnant de voir comment un jeu
comme ça enclenche des mécanismes dans
le cerveau tu dis vous façon dont je
joue loïc fait un générique s'il te
plaît
alors déjà si on parle d'une addiction
faut parler du type d'addiction il ya
trois types majeurs il ya des addictions
aux substances dites licite l'alcool le
sucre des choses comme ça aux substances
illicites
alors que vous faire la liste
je peux vous faire la liste vous savez
bien c'est tout ce qui est illégal et
les addictions sans supporte en support
matériel c'est à dire à l'argent au sexe
et au jeu aux jeux d'argent aux jeux
vidéo etc il faut bien se dire que
addictions et dépendances c'est pas
vraiment la même chose je me suis amusé
à lire des travaux de christian lüscher
c'est un médecin il est professeur de
neurosciences fondamentales à
l'université de genève j'ai des lectures
moi le soir tu vois j'avais une autre
vie bref il explique que l'addiction
c'est la consommation excessive d'une
substance sans tenir compte des
conséquences négatives qu'elle peut
avoir tandis que la dépendance c'est
quand on est victime du syndrome de
sevrage c'est à dire comme si on essaye
de se sevrer on n'arrive plus à dormir
en devient irritable ce genre de choses
m'ont en gros retenez juste que c'est
pas la même chose alors concernant les
addictions aux jeux vidéo spécifiquement
sans surprise c'est les jeunes qui sont
le plus touchés parce que belfort c'est
pourquoi ils jouent plus le jeu vidéo
que les autres encore plus s'il s'agit
de jeudi multijoueur parce que il ya un
lien qui se crée avec d'autres joueurs
donc on est on est même pas ce lot il ya
un lien social en plus qui vient
renforcer la diction les premiers jeux
en ligne multijoueurs et qui sont
apparus à peu près en 2000 et les
premiers phénomènes d'addiction qu'on
était vraiment constaté et référencer
ses 2005 et c'est là c'est là qu'on
rentre dans le vif du sujet pourquoi un
jeu ça peut rendre a dit pourquoi le jeu
fortnight particulièrement peut rendre
accro très facilement petit lys clémeur
avant d'aller un peu plus loin cette
vidéo la halle a pas pour but de
culpabiliser ou de dissuader les joueurs
qui prennent juste du plaisir dans leurs
temps libres un maul premier d'ailleurs
le but c'est surtout d'expliquer ce qui
se passe dans le cerveau des personnes
qui sont addicts comment le jeu forte
knight et les jeux vidéo en général
peuvent prendre trop certaines personnes
des personnes qui sont peut-être en
souffrance le tout en s'appuyant bien
sûr sur la vie des ex
vous l'avez compris mon exemple pour la
vidéo c'est fortnight mais il y en a
peut-être qui connaissent pas qui ne
connaît pas forte taille lever la main
moi j'ai joué une fois avec squeeze en
live je ne sais pas si vous avez vu la
vidéo à l'époque c'était pas beau à voir
c'est un jeu qui est sorti en 2010 est
qui est accessible gratuitement donc ça
c'est important et il ya deux modes de
jeu d'abord le mode save the world où tu
es dans un monde qui a infesté de
zombies il ya quatre joueurs qui vont
coopérer pour survivre et le mode battle
royale c'est cela le plus populaire où
tu as un joueur qui vont se confronter
sur une île l'objectif c'est qu'il reste
plus qu'à où éventuellement une équipe
de deux ou quatre joueurs donc c'est un
jeu qui est très sympa vraiment très
cool joly s'est il est très très bien on
passe d'excellents moments si on y passe
un temps raisonnable alors d'après vous
déjà mais combien de joueurs qui sont
inscrits à forte night il ya à peu près
autant de joueurs inscrits à forte nike
qui a d'habitants vous et ted lilly à
328 millions d'habitants aux états unis
il ya 350 millions d'inscrits à
fahrenheit et 40 millions de joueurs
mensuels dont 40 millions de joueurs
mensuels ça fait ça fait plus de la
moitié de la fin donc la question que je
me suis posée c'est pourquoi ce jeu rend
accro pourquoi les jeux vidéo en accro
mais pourquoi ce jeu là et j'ai lu les
travaux d'olivier fans un pédo
psychiatre et addictologue faut que je
lis des bd - un peu aussi et selon lui
fortnight à tous les ingrédients d'une
drogue déjà c'est gratuit c'est facile
d'accès c'est accessible sur téléphone
sur pc et sur consoles donc partout il
n'y a pas de difficultés le jeu est pas
ennuyeux parce qu'ils évoluent toujours
quand on y joue on a un sentiment de
progression donc on veut forcément
avancer et progresser et ça génère de
l'addiction parce que ils ont créé des
saisons avec des événements et les
événements si tu les fais pas ils seront
plus accessibles après ils sont en peau
réaliser autre ingrédient qui ressemble
principe d'une drogue les parties sont
très rapides donc on peut facilement
passer son temps de transport en commun
par exemple à jouer et après comme je le
disais en quelques mots tout à l'heure
il ya un aspect communautaire à ces
forces qui fait qu'un joueur peut se
sentir davantage intégré avec ses potes
d'école par exemple qui joue aussi et
c'est comme ça que certaines personnes
sont devenues des joueurs professionnels
d'ailleurs jusqu'à gagner de l'argent
donc ya pas que des points négatifs
comme je le disais tout à l'heure dans
le disque les moeurs clemmer d'ailleurs
en parlant de ça arrêtez avec les
commentaires qu'on lui dise les moeurs
tous les commentaires de il n'y a pas un
mot en français pour dire ça excusez moi
ça me choque par l'anglais les gars ça
fait longtemps qu'il ya des mois en mai
qui se sont intégrés dans notre langage
donc arrêté dans ces cas là de dire
week-end ou de dire un teaser par
exemple pour un film voilà c'est comme
ça c'est pas bien grave il ya des mots
anglais qui font partie de la langue
française je sens que ça va faire des
commentaires cette petite phrase je le
sens donc je vous parlais des joueurs
professionnels et bien le fait qu'ils
existent ça donne maintenant l'objectif
à d'autres joueurs de devenir aussi
joueur professionnel et puis il ya
l'excitation de remporter une partie
tout simplement
ça ça active le système de récompense
qu'il ya dans le cerveau n'a pas libéré
de la dopamine l'hormone du plaisir donc
une fois qu'on en a reçu une fois eh ben
on a envie de recommencer pour en
recevoir et ça c'est un peu dans tous
les domaines d'ailleurs mais c'est très
efficace sur les jeux vidéo alors là je
vous entends déjà dans les commentaires
j'entends vos claviers ou vous me dites
oui mais c'est le cas pour beaucoup de
jeu donc pourquoi forte ait en
particulier là on a d'autres hypothèses
pour ça déjà par principe d'égalité tout
le monde commence avec le même
équipement sur fortnight on rentre dans
une sorte de défi en mode si l'autre a
commencé avec les mêmes éléments que moi
moi aussi je peux y arriver donc il ya
un vrai aspect compétitif on va dire
juste fair play qui est très excitant
les graphismes du jeu qui sont hyper
flashy acidulées ils sont attrayants ça
donne envie de rester le jeu est
extrêmement simple à comprendre mais
l'élément clé c'est que le jeu est
bourré de récompenses y en a partout on
va être à la recherche de coffre à
trésors qui vont contenir des objets
dont a besoin le jeu c'est aussi un lieu
de rencontre pour tisser donc les liens
avec avec deux personnes qui ont la même
passion que nous c'est un peu une sorte
de réseau social dans un sens et puis à
des célébrités comme drake par exemple
qui ont qui ont dit jouer à forte knight
et ça ça peut donner envie aux joueurs
de jouer aussi parce que des gens que tu
estimes des gens très connus qui joue un
jeu dia est ce qu'il est moi aussi je
joue comme lui du coup on a la même vie
d'ailleurs petit fun fact fortnight
c'est le premier jeu qui a lancé des
concerts en live incroyable ou pas
c'était en 2020 et c'est le rappeur très
lisse cote qui est qui qui a joué en
live sur fortnight avec un avatar de lui
géant et tout le show a été vu 12
on deux fois donc en réalité qui fait le
côté vraiment addictif de forte taille
c'est la dimension sociale du jeu ce que
fortnight à à créer un univers à part
entière je résume un jeu ultra intuitif
facile gratuit qui évolue avec le temps
compétitifs on peut commencer une partie
vite fait on peut jouer sur tous les
supports il ya tous les ingrédients
comme pour une drogue de créer une
routine quotidienne et l'intégrer
plusieurs fois dans sa journée à sa vie
et avec le système de récompenses etc
donc c'est il ya toutefois il ya
tellement tout que epic games ce qu'on
crée le jeu forsythe ont été attaqués
par un cabinet d'avocats pourquoi parce
que le cabinet d'avocats reproche à epic
games d'avoir volontairement créé un jeu
très addictif est le plus troublant dans
tout ça c'est que l'avocate as appel à
l'efsf un drap et pau sitôt chartrand
elle elle dit elle affirme même que epic
games a engagé quand ils ont créé le jeu
des psychologues pour creuser dans le
cerveau humain et rendre le jeu aussi
addictif que possible alors est ce que
c'est vrai est ce que c'est vrai j'ai
creusé j'ai creusé après ça a fait un
trou dans le jardin donc j'ai reboucher
et après j'ai fait des recherches et
j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé célia howden tu
entres autres mais elle si le docteur en
psychologie cognitive elle a participé à
la conception du jeu de forte taille
elle a pu analyser l'attitude des
joueurs dans une salle de test à l'appui
rentes des conclusions et j'ai trouvé un
article où elle dit la chose suivante le
challenge pour nous était donc de
s'assurer que les joueurs comprennent
très vite comment construire des choses
et qu'ils y prennent rapidement du
plaisir c'est de la psychologie
behavioriste simple petite parenthèse
pour vous le sait la science du
comportement en gros ensuite elle dit
les joueurs expérimentés d un feedback
positif au négatif et les apprennent par
association on essaie de les placer le
plus possible dans une situation ils
peuvent apprendre en faisant par
l'expérimentation le plaisir du jeu
vient de là de trouver des solutions
soit même à des problèmes donc on est
sûr d'une chose c'est que les
concepteurs ont fait en sorte de rendre
le jeu le plus accrocheur possible mais
c'est logique ils veulent pas que les
joueurs décrochent quand on quand il
joue mais ce qui leur a permis de faire
ça c'est le système de récompense du jeu
et si vous vous posez la question pour
le procès il n'y a pas eu de décision de
justice de rendu pour le moment si c'est
le cas je vous tiendrai au courant alors
il ya un a dit un truc aussi dans on n'a
pas parlé le jeu est gratuit certes mais
les joueurs peuvent dépenser la moue là
pour acheter des nouveaux looks pour les
avatars des outils d'être comme ça là il
ya un autre point développé j'ai trouvé
un sondage qui a été réalisé en 2018 il
a été réalisé par l'inde est due à
propos de fortes night 69 % des
personnes sondées avaient acheté des
objets dans le jeu
69% 69% c'est énorme signe d'un geek
mais ce qui est encore plus fou c'est
que dans la même étude on s'aperçoit que
36% des personnes qui ont acheté un truc
dans fahrenheit n'avait jamais dépenser
de l'argent dans n'importe quel autre
jeu vidéo il n'avait jamais fait des
achats in app ou d'autres choses comme
ça sachant que l'étude est plutôt portée
sur les gros joueurs on voit que
l'addiction va aussi entraîner des
achats et des achats compulsifs et quand
on a 15 ans qu'on n'a pas trop de sous
et qu'on utilise la carte bancaire des
parents sans leur demander c'est un peu
chaud il ya des personnes il ya des
précédents de sacs ont dépensé plusieurs
milliers d'euros juste pour changer le
look de leur avatar avec la carte bleue
des parents qui se disaient mais allez
où ma carte en ce moment là je n'ai pas
trouvé et grâce à ça parce qu'on parle
quand même d'un jeu gratuit fortnight
fait 300 millions de dollars de recettes
par mois 300 millions de dollars de
recettes par mois pour un jeu gratuit
voilà c'est pour vous donner un petit
ordre d'idée et pour vous dire regardez
le principe addictif de ce type de jeu
ça peut générer ça derrière après quand
c'est bien huilé et ses jeux prenez
l'exemple d'un ado de 15 ans en espagne
à un adolescent de 15 ans qui a été
hospitalisé à cause de la diction qu'il
avait un portail pour être je cite un
désintoxiqué il passé entre 18 heures et
20 heures par jour sur le jeu ça veut
dire il lui reste quatre heures pour
dormir manger donc plus de vie sociale
très clairement échec scolaire
évidemment et manque de sommeil à cause
de la sueur activation du système de
récompense la personne va avoir du mal à
trouver du plaisir dans un autre domaine
c'est ça le piège c'est que du coup on
ne veut que la récompense qu'on a dans
le jeu vidéo là en l'occurrence mais de
son addiction il n'y a plus rien d'autre
qui nous procure le même plaisir c'est
pour ça qu'on y retourne et quand ce
système de récompense et sursollicités
ça engendre des tensions ça rend
irritable et là on commence à tomber
dans un truc mauvais parce qu'on ne
prend pas vraiment de plaisir à jouer
mais en fait on joue par nécessité parce
qu'on peut pas ressentir le manque de
caen pas et c'est le cas pour tous les
types d'addictions ça j'ai lu un rapport
du centre hospitalier universitaire
vaudois abonnez-moi picsou magazine ont
changé mes lectures dans ce rapport en
gros ils disent que le fait d'être jeune
d'être célibataire d'être impulsif et
introverti de vivre une période
difficile de pas sentir grave qui fait
dans la vraie vie ou d'avoir vécu une
expérience traumatisante ça peut faire
basculer encore plus facilement dans une
addiction et encore plus dans celle de
l'addiction aux jeux vidéo et
l'adolescent en espagne dont je vous
parle là de 15 ans qui a été hospitalisé
pour son addiction à forte knight avait
une vraie fragilité parce que il venait
de perdre sa mère donc ça a créé une
combinaison comme ça mental un peu un
truc un peu infernal là vous vous dites
fabien c'est bien tous ces problèmes est
ce qu'à un moment donné tu as une
solution et bien j'ai peut-être une
solution celle du psychologue michael
stora il a trouvé une manière de soigner
l'addiction au jeu fortnight par un
autre jeu zelda
tin tin tin tin tin tin tin tin comme
tantôt tard je vous jure que c'est vrai
le gars a soigné plein d'adolescents
vraiment qui est accro à fortnight grâce
à zelda breath of the wild précisément
parce que fortnight c'est un jeu on y
pulsionnel c'est un jeu de pulsions
alors que zelda sa confronte un joueur
au calme et dans une interview le
psychologue a expliqué que le joueur
allait retrouver du sens aux faits
d'avancé dans un jeu qui est pas
uniquement fait pour flinguer l'autre
mais pour pouvoir avancer pour sa propre
réussite personnelle c'est un jeu qu'est
narratif donc on va être confronté à
beaucoup de personnages qui sont non
jouables que des pnj et en plus on peut
faire des espèces de transfert des
personnages qu'on voit dans le jeu avec
les personnages notre vraie vie par
exemple le temps breath of the wild si
si vous y avez joué au départ on voit le
grand père et tout cas en fait le roi
mais faut pas le dire parce que si vous
faisiez pas je viens de vous spoiler fcb
ça ça peut le roi peut nous faire penser
à notre grand père par exemple si on
avait un grand père droit tarik tous les
personnages du jeu de zelda sont un peu
comme deco thérapeute qui vont régler
cette addiction au jeu de pulsions comme
portail tout de jeu après si je vous
donne mon avis perso ils n'ont pas pris
en compte un truc mais moi par exemple
dans breath of the wild il fallait
absolument que je que je fasse tous les
temples que j'ai toutes les noix que je
fasse le jeu à quasi 100 % quoi enfin
pas kazire à 100% ça on n'en parle pas
ça alors ça c'est pas de la diction
c'est l'obsession donc
pour le mec comme moi ça crée des
obsession de je veux le finir à 100%
vous êtes comme ça où il ya que moi dans
les autres solutions auxquelles on peut
penser il ya par exemple kino thérapie
c'est assez incroyable ça fonctionne
bien pour pour traiter les phobies les
angoisses mais aussi du coup les
addictions et puis il ya plein de sites
internet qui sont dédiés pour les autres
problématiques liés aux addictions ski
l'achat compulsif g d'argent jeux vidéo
etc je voulais mais en description si
jamais vous ou quelqu'un de votre
entourage est confrontée comme ça une
addiction vous pouvez lui passer la
vidéo et tous les liens sont en bas il
ya trois ans sur la chaîne j'avais fait
une vidéo courte où je présente un livre
sur l'addiction qui s'appelle
sommes-nous addict c'est un peu une mise
à jour d'ailleurs cette vidéo
aujourd'hui de ce que j'avais fait à
l'époque dieu pourquoi ça arrive de
l'addiction commencent à arriver des
solutions pour s'en sortir tout ça si ça
vous intéresse vous voulez aller plus
loin dans ce sujet ou dans la recherche
de solutions si vous en souffrez aussi
quelqu'un d'autre autour de vous en
souffrent je voulais également le lien
de la vidéo dans la description et le
livre aussi dans la description
évidemment ici et ici il joue mais deux
autres vidéos sur le cerveau qui devrait
vous intéresser en tout cas si cette
vidéo là vous a plu c'est sûr que ces
deux vidéos là vont vous plaire je les
ai pas choisis au hasard si vous ne
connaissez pas je m'appelle fabien
olicard bonjour je suis mentaliste et
oui ce métier existe encore est ce que
c'est vraiment un métier d'ailleurs et
j'écris des livres je fais des
spectacles sur scène depuis plus de dix
ans et apparemment je raconte ma vie en
fin de vidéo à des gens qui a pris aux
mêmes connaissent déjà sinon abonnez
vous prenez soin de vous à très bientôt
ciao